abone ol
en iyi akşamlar Hoş geldiniz Biz takdim
ettiler Ama ben yine ben Dr Gülseren
budayıcıoğlu diye başlayayım pskiyatri
Steam psikiyatri hocalarından ve
kitaplardan hayatı ise hayatını nasıl
gerçeklerini hep hastalarından öğrendim
onlar Öğrettiler bana çünkü kırk küsür
yıldır onları dinliyorum ve Dinledikçe
Dinledikçe burada sanki keşfedilmeyi
bekleyen bir Gizem var bir şey var benim
görmem gereken ve son yıllarda Özellikle
bu konuya eğilmeye ve bu konuda
çalışmaya başladım şimdi size de birkaç
örnek vereyim
bu psikiyatri zaten hep geçmişimizle
çocukluğumuzla orada yaşadıklarımızla
bugün arasında bir ilişki kurmaya hep
gayret etmiştir Ben de bu ilişkinin
Bizim sandığımızdan daha net bir ilişki
olduğunu ve birinin bunu girip burada
bir formül var bir şey var keşfedilmeyi
Bekleyen bunu görmesi gerekiyor Şu Size
birkaç örnekle başlayayım mesela birçok
çipik çok sık gördüm ve örneklerden bir
tanesi bir hanım gelir der ki ya
evleneceğim işte Ama benim babam alkolik
te ya alkolik olmasın yeter ben başka
bir özellik istemiyorum sonra bir süre
sonra bir bakarım ki
da alkolik veya hanım hanım ayrılır
eşinden işte tekrar evlenme peşindedir
şartları olacağı ettiriyor dur der ki
amana beni dövmesinde ben çok bıktım
şiddetten dayaktan başka bir şey
istemiyorum bir bakarım ki evet yani ay
hiç anlamadım ama hiç de görmedim tahmin
etmedim ama adam ok Şiddeti en iyi
gösteren adam burada bir gariplik var
Yani bu bu kadar da net olur musun böyle
diyor insan Ben de öyle dedim ve bunu
araştırdıkça gördükçe sonradan adına da
kader motifi i dedim bu kavramın ben
sonra niye kadar motifi dediğimi de
sizlere anlatmak isterim
o Çünkü motif deyince bilmiyorum gençler
biliyorlar mı Ama hani evde annelerimiz
bize battaniye Örer işte danteller
örerler filan Derler ki önce bir motif
çıkaralım sonra aynı motifi tekrar
tekrar örebilir koca bir battaniye bir
örtü çıkar ortaya Ve gördüm ki
insanoğlunda da her ne kadar Bizler son
derece akıllı hep mükemmeli arayan her
gün Yarını dünden daha üstün daha
gelişmiş kılmaya çalışan ve dünyanın
Efendisi olduğumuza inanan varlıklarda
olsak bütün kararlarımızı son derece
bilinçli düşüne taşına aldığımızı da
sazan netsec Bir de baktım ki İşler pek
de öyle geçmiyor buna önce kendi
hayatıma bakarak yola çıktım insan en
iyi kendini
bu tür dedim ve kendimden çıktım yola
Ben bugüne nasıl geldim Nereden geldin
benim Geçmişimle bu günüm arasında nasıl
bir ilişki var Nasıl bir paralellik var
bunların da peşine düştükten sonra bugün
size anlatacağım Kader motifinin aslında
bir yazılım bir bilgisayar programı
olduğunu gördüm yani önce Şişt em
kendini yaratıyor küçük bir çekirdek
yaratıyor şu sonra bu çekirdeği anayasa
kabul ediyor ve bu çekirdeği hayat boyu
biraz geliştirerek tekrar tekrar tekrar
bize Yaşatmaya devam ediyor Biz Sezen'le
Diyoruz ki ya işte biz hangi meslekte
çalışacağız kendimiz karar verdik
kiminle evleneceğiz kendimiz karar
o nerede çalışacağız nasıl bir hayatımız
olsun hangi nerede yaşayalım bütün
bunları bir düşündük taşındık Bize en
uygunu bulduk Meğer işler işte öyle
değilmiş Evet biz karar alıyoruz ama
bizi o karar zaten Oo sistem hazırlıyor
bizim Baştan hangi kararı alacağımız o
biliyor zaten Ha biz de geriye ne
kalıyor bu kararı niye aldığımız Iy
bahanelerini bulmak hayat bahane
bulmakta çok mahirdir İşte biz öyle
yaptık Çünkü filan diye altında bunun en
iyi şekilde dolduruyoruz zaten bu
çekirdek şöyle gelişiyor Sevgili
arkadaşlarım şimdi bir bebek Hayal
edelim Ben biliyorsunuz Bu son olarak da
doğduğun ev Kaderindir diye bir dizi
Üzerinde çalışıyorum gel
ya sen de doğduğumuz ev bizim kaderimiz
yazıyor bir nasıl yazıyor bir bebek bir
eve dünyadan fırlatılıp geliyor çaresiz
bir bebek bebeğin dünyaya geldiğinde ki
tek kişi ilahı sesi ve yani bebeğim en
iyi bildiği şey bol bol ağlamak tepinmek
Ortalığı ayağa kaldırarak şeyi
bulabilmek yani yardım alabilmek çünkü
sağ yavrusu kendi başına ayakta
durabilen bir canlı değil O nedenle
bebek dünyaya geldiği anda Önce bakın
kodu var Sahibini arıyor ve dikkat edin
çocuklarınız sorunlarınız kardeşleriniz
doğduğu gün bebek sahibini arar ve
sahibine hemen tanır derhal onu kendine
bağlamaya
o gözüne öyle bir bakar ki onunla öyle
bir ilişki kurmaya gayret eder ki Çünkü
bilir ki eğer sahibi olmazsa hayatta
kalamayacak bakın bebek Bunu bilerek
Dünyaya Geliyor bebeğin sadece bir tane
duygusu var Ona hakim tek bir duyguya
sahip bebek korku korku neye karşı
hayatta kalabilecek miyim yoksa Bir
tehlike mi var bütün canlıların ortak
duygusudur korku ve bu korku duygusu
sayesinde kendimizi tehlikelerden
koruruz şimdi bebek ilk günden itibaren
hayatta kalabilmek için o korku
duygusuyla birlikte bakıyor hayata ben
nasıl kendimi koruyabilirim kendi
koruyacak sahibi Onu koruyacak nasıl bir
il
o kurmalıyım ki sahibim L50 bırakmışsın
2 3 bu sanki o bebeğin içinde bir kayıt
cihazı ya da çok gelişmiş bugün hayal
bile edemediğimiz kadar gelişmiş bir
bilgisayar var öyle bir bilgisayar yada
kayıt cihazı ki o ortamda var olan
herşeyi kaydeden bir cihaz bu renkleri
resimleri sesleri kokuları ve daha da
önemlisi o ortamın duygularını şimdi bu
kaydı yaparken bilgisayarın bir hedefi
var veya o kayıt cihazının bir hedefi
var Hedef şu bilmediği bir yerde
gözlerini açtı kendine ait tek duygusu
korku korku o
bu Fatih zaman ortaya çıkan huzur
bebekleri düşünün Hani bölümü suyu mışıl
uyurlar gayet sakin arada bir gülerek
filan işte O anlar bebeğin korku
duygusunun kaybolduğu anlardır o bebek
için ona mutluluk da diyebiliriz şimdi
Demek ki bebeğin hedefine bu korkudan
kurtulup bu hedefe yani huzura
erişebilmek şimdi bu bilgisayar bu
kayıtları neden yapıyor peki Onun da
hedefi şu Ben nasıl bir program yazayım
ki bu korkudan kurtulup bu çok sevdiğim
için de çok huzur duyduğum diğer tarafa
geçebilirim bunu kuralları ne Bu Dünya
nasıl bir yer ki şu bu dünya bu dünya
diyorum Çünkü bebeğin Dünyası o doğduğu
evin dünyasıdır ya
bu dünyayı o evler temsil eder önce
Sadece anne sonra anne baba sonra
Kardeşler Belki evde büyükler falan ama
sonuç olarak o ev dünyayı simgeler çocuk
için ve o içimizdeki bilgisayar için
Sonuç olarak Hedef bu arzularla yani
keyfi a huzurunu mutluluğunu bulabilmek
için ben bu dünya ile nasıl bir ilişki
kurmalıyım ki bu hedefe ulaşabileceğim
Ben şimdi anne Oo zaten dört gözle
beklemiş Gözü hep bebeğin üstünde Amanın
işte yedim içtim mi ağladığımı bir şey
mi eksik Aman altımı ıslandı üşüdüğümü
böyle bir ortamda bebekle rahat
bilgisayarda rahatsız fazla uğraşmaya
gerek yok ya
Bu bir şey yapmasam da dünya beni kabul
etti onayladı fazla çalışmama gerek yok
böyle bir program hazırlıyor veya bir
bebek orada kıyameti koparıyor ağlıyor
bağırıyor fakat anne meşgul Annenin
başka işleri var Annenin kendine ait
başka sorunları var ya da da annenin
Uğurlu değil yani Zaten istememiş de
bebeği Hay Allah yani ölse de kurtulsam
ki böyle bebeklerde maalesef dünyaya
geliyorlar şu ya da bu nedenle şimdi o
bilgisayarın o sistem inişi zor hayatta
kalabilmek için çok şey öğrenmesi
gerekiyor hayatta kalabilmek için o
yaşında mücadele etmeyi öğrenmesi
gerekiyor nerede susacak nerede
ağlayacak kendinin onlara nasıl kabul
ettirecek bir de annen
Ya ben bakacak Hiç ağlamayacak mı canı
bile yapsa anne sokulmaya mı çalışacak
ona yaranmaya mı çalışacak derken İşte
bu bebekler sıfırla yüz arasında bir
sıralamaya tabi tutarsak çok perişan Çok
keyifli bebek arasında binlerce değişik
seçenekler içinde yavaş yavaş büyümeye
devam ediyoruz Yedi yaşına geldiğinde
bir çocuk Artık o Sistem aşağı yukarı
oluşmuştur o sistem dediğimiz değil ömrü
boyunca kullanacağız sistem artık Oo
yaranmaya mı çalışacak hep Boyun mu
ölçek hep İsyanlı edecek Hep onun
hakkını mı yiyecekler ama canım Senden
adam olmaz mı diyecekler yer şimdi bu
kayıt Buna göre yapılmaya devam ediliyor
yedi yaşından sonra aşağı yukarı
bu Gerçek dünya ile tanışma zamanıdır
yani okul başlar işte arkadaşlarla
ilişkiler başlar Bu sefer burada bir
dünyaya göre bir program yapıldı Ama Bu
programla Dış Dünya birbirine tuttu mu
tutmadı mı Bir de burada şöyle bir
program kendine elden geçirir aşağı
yukarı 15 yaşına geldiğimizde program
artık kendileri tamamlamıştır bir ve bu
tamamladı program Gerçi o biz ölene
kadar hayatta kaldığımız ve aklımız
başımızda olduğu sürece o kayıt cihazı
çalışmaya ve sistem etkilenmeye açıktır
Ama artık bir yazılım bilgisayara
girmiştir nasıl Siz bilgisayarınızda
kullandığınız programa bu program size
ne verir ne vermez biliyorsunuz değil mi
yani
bu programda bu Yoksa bunu size vermez
bu program işte Kader motifi de o
çekirdek sistem Yani kendini sürekli
tekrar eder sistemde Meğer programda
yoksa size cevap vermez ve o bildiğini
okumaya devam eder şimdi buradan şu
sorular akla gelebilir İyi de yani biz
Burak mahkumuyuz yani Biz bunu hiç
değiştiremez miyiz bu programı bu
yazılımı değiştirmenin tek yolu bunu
zamanında o farkındalığı geliştirebilmek
triki Bu farkındalığı nasıl kullanacağız
şöyle kullanacağız
Evet Ee bu yazılım Artık insanlar da
yani Bizler de refleks haline gelmiştir
Yani şöyle bir tavır karşısında biz
nasıl tepki göstereceğiz Hayır diyeceğiz
o kendiliğinden Biz düşünüp taşınmadan o
Hayır bizden çıkar veya pardon Evet
diyeceğiz boyun eğmeyeceğiz veya İsyan
edeceğiz veya gülücez veya başımıza
iyice zor refleks olarak bu tepki
gösterir bir Eğer Bizler bu refleks
tepkileri bu yazılımı Park edebilirsek
İşte o zaman bizim aklımız bilincimiz
yani İnsan zekası ve aklı bilinçdışı
yerine bilincin kendisi devreye
girebilir ve bir dakika ya
de hayır dedim Ama ben buna niye hayır
dedim Niye ben bunları hep ayırıyorum
Hatta ben kitaplarımda şöyle cümlelerim
var Ben de seviyorum bu cümleleri bu
Kaderimiz doğduğumuz evlerde yazılır o
evlerde yaralanır ve bizi o yaraların
götürdüğü yere gideriz gerçekten de
bizim Kaderimize esas yazanlar orada
aldığımız yaralardır Ama bu yaralar bizi
çok perişan da edebilir bu yaralar
yüzünden dünya lideri işte çok büyük bir
mucit büyük bir sanatçı da olabiliriz ya
da bu aşkla ilgili yine kitaplarında
yazdığım bir cümle vardır bir çocukken
yaşadığımız Orço
Allah acılarımızı bize yeniden yaşatacak
kişileri gözünden tanır ve başkasına
değil gider ona aşık oluruz Niye Çünkü o
kararı o yazılım çoktan onu tanıdı ve
bize ve onları tekrar yaşatmanın yolunu
arıyor O son cümle Peki bu yazılım veya
Kader motifi Bize Düşman mı Yani neden
bize ısrarla bu acıları yaşatıyor bunun
cevabını da şöyle verebilirim O bize
düşman değil Ooo Dünya ile baş etmede en
iyi tanıdığı yöntemi kullanmak istiyor
yabancı bir ortam şöyle diyelim hep
dayak yemiş bir kadın çocukluğundan beri
önce
3D sonra eşinde Bu kadının en iyi uyum
yapmayı öğrendiği yer o şiddet gördüğü
yerdir Çünkü o güne kadar o ortamda
sürdürmüş hayatını onu çok başka böyle
el üstünde taşıyan bir ortama
getirirseniz dünyandan bir yanıyla
Bunlar çok hoşlanır ama bir yanıyla
orayla nasıl ilişki kuracak nereye kadar
inanıp nereye inanmayacak ona bu kadar
saygı ve ilgi gösteren insanlara nasıl
tepki gösterdi Bunu bilmez o oranın
yabancıdır başka bir ülkedir orası Onun
için hepimiz için durum ve maalesef
arkadaşlarım budur niçin Kader motif
imizi bir an önce tanımaya çalışan Çok
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]